after 13 weeks of mass demonstrations
the crackdown takes on a darker shade
for the first time police fired water
cannons loaded with blue dye staining
frontline protesters and promising to
prosecute them authorities and warn Hong
Kong residents not to participate in the
banned demonstrations thousands defied
them the purpose of hitting the streets
today is to tell the government you
can't scare us this way we also have to
restate our main demands because they've
never responded to them back on the
street prominent activist Joshua Wong
just a day after being arrested then
released activist being threatened by
police been bitten by those police force
reports the price I pay is really small
so I have no reason to give up
[Music]
it began with a hymn demonstrators
calling they're gathering a religious
meeting in an attempt to circumvent the
ban on protests the chorus grew louder
as thousands joined in a peaceful march
but the tune changed as the scene turned
chaotic with tear gas from police fire
bombs from protesters and by night
burning barricades blocking the streets
this weekend marks the fifth anniversary
of China's decision not to allow full
democratic elections in Hong Kong yet
the flames of resistance burn on
and joining me now from Hong Kong is DW
correspondent Charlotte gelsin Pill
Charlotte protesters have been on the
move all day what's the latest where you
are right now well at the moment we're
in the busy shopping district Causeway
Bay during the day this is bustling
tonight though again it is the scene of
carnage once more at the moment there is
a huge police presence as I'm sure you
can see behind me a short time ago
police deployed a tear gas at large
amounts of protestors who'd moved over
here many of them setting up barricades
okay it's being satellites police then
charged through and the protesters were
largely dispersed since then no we've
seen a number of arrests of the
stragglers of those protesters who were
left behind they were bundled into
police vans what we're hearing is those
protesters now moving on to another
location this is very much a
cat-and-mouse game car that's been
repeated not just tonight but throughout
these 13 weeks protesters gather in one
place and then they move on and police
follow them tear gas and multiple
different locations to be clear what is
happening in Hong Kong is not in
isolated places this is somewhere that
is that it's extremely widespread
Charlotte we were just seeing pictures
there of those fires that were set in
the streets that you mentioned is this a
sign do you think that protesters are
now more willing to use violent tactics
than they were before
well we've seen protesters on the front
lines using the fire multiple times in
the past in recent weeks we've seen them
throwing Molotov cocktails the fire
projectiles essentially at police that's
something that we saw again today we
have also have seen them as setting
light to bins in the streets that's
something we've seen again today but
there have been it seems many more this
evening as protesters do try and build
up those barricades to try and prevent
the police from getting closer to them
it would seem this is a potentially you
could see this as an escalation in
violence on both sides police today
using that water cannon once again
that's the second time within 13 weeks
last time being last Sunday but for the
first time that blue dye was used by
police as well crucially people think to
to mark to identify those protesters who
were on the front line so that they can
be found later and possibly arrested
today's protests come a day after more
activists were arrested but that doesn't
seem to have deterred most protesters
they're in the streets that's right a
number of high-profile activists were
arrested as well as legislators
yesterday in a big sweep unprecedented
in this movement so far of course 900
people have been arrested over the last
13 weeks but the fact that these people
who were arrested yesterday was so
high-profile did alarm a lot of
protesters nevertheless they have been
out on the streets today very peacefully
earlier on today
marching defiant in the face of the
threat of arrest something that police
have said that they do face this is
after all an unauthorized protest police
have repeatedly made clear that anyone
who is on the streets today is acting
illegally nevertheless a lot of people
on the streets today they told us that
while they fit repercussions from
authorities what they fear more is what
they see as the encroachment from
Beijing on their riots here in Hong Kong
cw's Charlotte Johnson pill in Hong Kong
for us thank you very much